Rugir is a tree, isn't it? It's an air-cooled
meran dahda with this snake What is it?  I'm obliged to
do it, it's sunny Hey,
I'm making a job a Ah
I'm always strict, so I
wonder if everyone can avoid
me Maybe I'm timid how to understand my work
Isn't the minister supposed to be weak?  Well, it's
always like this,
ex-everyone, the atmosphere is tight, and the
competition can be erased in the mating loss club.
Temporary office,
slave question, what, the
army has returned and started preaching,
but I don't understand what you're saying at all
.
Niga Daibun I just got 3 pieces of information from the upper part and the app Choji app Choji Kimura Jean alone yeah yeah
me
[music] go
to hill station this
Agastia day with a high receipt
ie
it's good that everyone is going  I really liked tragedy
[music]